de vous présenter
son Excellence Vladimir Zelenski
président de l'Ukraine
merci beaucoup
merci
c'est trop pour moi
tout cela c'est pour notre grand peuple
pour notre grand peuple merci
chers américains
dans tous les états toutes les villes
dans toutes les collectivités
vous tous ce qui respectait la liberté
la justice qui
chérissaient tout autant que nous
ukrainien nos villes et nos familles
j'espère que mes paroles de respect et
de gratitude trouveront un écho dans
tous les cœurs Américains
madame la vice-présidente
je vous remercie pour les efforts que
vous avez fait pour aider l'Ukraine
madame la présidente de la Chambre vous
avez courageusement visiter l'Ukraine en
pleine guerre merci beaucoup c'est un
grand honneur
[Applaudissements]
c'est un privilège pour moi d'être ici
char membre du Congrès représentant des
représentants des deux parties qui
avaient aussi visité Kiev
représentant cher sénateur et sénatrice
les deux parties qui allaient visiter
l'Ukraine j'en suis sûr un jour
chers représentante et représentants de
la diaspora
[Applaudissements]
ici et dans ce pays chers membres de la
presse c'est un grand honneur pour moi
d'être ici au Congrès des États-Unis et
de vous adresser la parole à vous et à
tout le peuple américain
malgré l'horreur
l'Ukraine n'est pas tombée l'Ukraine et
vivante
les graines se battent
[Applaudissements]
cela me permet
de vous parler de notre victoire nous
avons vaincu la Russie aux yeux du monde
nous n'avons aucune crainte et personne
dans le monde ne devrait craindre
l'Ukraine a remporté cette victoire elle
doit nous donner le courage et elle
devrait inspirer le monde entier
les Américains
ont remporté cette victoire et vous avez
réussi à unir la communauté mondiale
pour protéger la liberté et le droit les
Européens remporté cette victoire et
c'est pourquoi vous êtes plus
indépendant et plus fort que jamais la
tyrannie russe a perdu le contrôle qu'il
exerçait sur nous
[Applaudissements]
et cela ne va elle ne va plus jamais
influencer notre pensée
nous devons aussi faire en sorte que le
sud global remporte cette victoire
une des choses les plus importantes
c'est que les Russes ne pourront être
libre que lorsqu'ils auront renversé le
Kremlin dans leurs esprits
cependant la bataille se poursuit et il
nous faut battre le kremelin sur le
champ de bataille et cette bataille
n'est pas seulement pour
telle ou telle territoire ça n'est pas
seulement pour l'Europe pas seulement
pour la vie la liberté et les Ukrainiens
ou de toute autre nation que la Russie
voudrait conquérir ce combat va définir
dans quel monde nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants vivront et leurs enfants
et leurs petits-enfants elle déterminera
si ce sera dans une démocratie du
kremien une démocratie d’américaine une
démocratie pour tous et pour toutes
cette bataille ne veut pas être remise à
plus tard elle ne peut pas être ignorée
en espérant que
nous protège
des États-Unis à la Chine de l'Europe à
l'Amérique latine et de l'Afrique à
l'Australie
[Musique]
le monde est trop interrelié trop
interdépendant pour que quelqu'un puisse
s'isoler et se penser en sécurité alors
qu'une telle bataille se poursuit nos
deux nations sont alliées dans cette
bataille et l'année prochaine sera un
tournant je le sais ce sera le moment où
le courage des
Ukrainiens et la détermination des
États-Unis assureront notre liberté la
liberté des personnes qui défendent leur
valeur
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs
mesdames Messieurs chers américains hier
avant de venir ici à Washington j'étais
sur la ligne de front à
sur nos points forts dans l'est de
l'Ukraine dans le Donbass
l'armée russe
a bombardé barmouth sans répit depuis le
mois de mai ils l'ont attaqué nuit et
jour mais darkmoutier bon
la Sierre l'année dernière
70 000 personnes vivaient à
et chaque pouce de ce territoire est
trempé de sang
les canons ne cessent de retentir
[Musique]
et les combats sont soutenus mais
les Ukrainiens de donc basse résistent
[Applaudissements]
les Russes
utilise toutes les ressources qu'ils ont
contre barthout est autre belle ville
les
[Musique]
occupants ont un avantage important sur
le plan de l'artillerie ils ont un
avantage sur le plan des munitions ils
ont beaucoup plus de missiles
que nous n'en pouvons avoir c'est vrai
mais notre défense tiens bon
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes tous fiers de nos
défenseurs
les tactiques russes sont primitives il
détruisent tout ce qu'il voit
ils envoient des prisonniers se battent
en première ligne
il font la même chose que les autres
tyrannie dans le passé
il
comme les braves soldats américains qui
ont combattu les forces d'Hitler
à la Noël 1944 les soldats Ukrainiens
font la même chose aujourd'hui il se
battent contre les forces de Poutine à
ce Noël
[Applaudissements]
se rendra jamais
en première ligne la tyrannie qui fait
preuve de cruauté contre les personnes
mais votre soutien est indispensable non
seulement pour poursuivre le combat mais
pour atteindre ce tournant pour
remporter la bataille sur le terrain
nous avons de l'artillerie oui merci
est-ce que nous en avons assez non pas
vraiment
tu es une
barre
seulement une plateforme mais il faut
que l'armée russe se retire il nous faut
plus de canon plus de munitions
de notre lutte pour l'indépendance et
pour la liberté
si vos patriotes
la terreur russe contre nos villes Slava
nous permettre de défendre pleinement
notre liberté
[Applaudissements]
c'est la Russie ne peut atteindre nos
villes l'essai de les détruire par des
attaques de missiles et la Russie
recourir à une politique de génocide et
l'Iran a envoyé en Russie des
armes qui viennent attaquer nos
infrastructures
c'est une question de temps
avant que la Russie n'attaque vos autres
alliés si nous ne les stockons pas
maintenant nous devons les arrêter
[Applaudissements]
je crois que
nous n'avons jamais demandé aux soldats
américains de venir se battre sur notre
sol à notre place et non je vous assure
que les soldats ukrainien peuvent
parfaitement utilisés des charges
Américains et des avions américains ils
peuvent certainement les utiliser
eux-mêmes
[Applaudissements]
l'aide financière est aussi d'une
importance cruciale et je veux vous
remercier vous remercier beaucoup
pour
les programmes d'aide financière que
vous nous avez accordé et pour ce sur
lesquels vous aurez à décider
cet argent ce n'est pas de la charité
c'est un investissement dans la sécurité
mondiale et dans la démocratie et c'est
un acte responsable que c'était
financière que vous nous accordez
la Russie
pourrait arrêter son agression si elle
le voulait
mais vous pouvez accélérer notre
victoire je le sais
et cela va trouver à tous les agresseurs
potentiels que personne ne peut violer
les frontières ne peut commettre
d'atrocité et
écraser les gens contre leur volonté
et cela imposera la Russie de faire des
pas pour vers la paix les russes
continuent d'être empoisonnés par le
Kremlin
nous avons besoin de la paix oui
l'Ukraine a déjà présenté des
propositions
j'en ai discuté avec le président Baden
une formule en 10 points qui devra être
appliqué pour assurer notre sécurité
pour des décennies à venir
et je suis heureux de dire que le
président baiden appuie notre initiative
de paix aujourd'hui chacune et chacun de
vous peuvent aider l'application de
cette formule pour que le leadership
américain reste solide
il faut un appui un appui bien partisan
un appui des deux chambres merci
vous pouvez renforcer les sanctions pour
que la Russie comprenne à quel point
cette agression est ruineuse vous avez
le pouvoir de nous aider à porter devant
la justice ceux qui ont causé cette
guerre cette invasion non provoquée
[Applaudissements]
que l'on demandait compte à l'état
terroriste et qu'il soit obligé
d'indemniser pour les dommages causés
par cette guerre montrez-moi que les
États-Unis sont là mesdames messieurs
chers
dans deux jours nous allons célébrer
Noël
nous allons allumer des bougies
mais nous allons faire parce que c'est
plus romantique parce que nous n'avons
pas d'électricité des millions de
personnes n'auront ni au courant que ni
chauffage
tout cela à cause des attaques de
missiles et de drones des Russes sur nos
infrastructures énergétiques
mais nous ne nous plaignons pas
nous ne jugeons pas qui a la vie la plus
facile
votre bien-être est le fruit de votre
sécurité nationale le résultat des
luttes que vous avez menées pour
défendre votre liberté nous aussi nous
allons vivre notre guerre d'indépendance
et de liberté nous allons la mener dans
la dignité et avec succès
[Applaudissements]
nous allons célébrer Noël
nous allons célébrer Noël et même si
nous n'avons pas d'électricité la
lumière de notre foi notre lumière
intérieure ne sera pas déteste
si les missiles russes nous attaquent
nous allons faire de notre mieux pour
nous protéger
s'il nous attaque avec des drones
iraniens et que nos gens doivent se
réfugier dans les abris le jour de Noël
les
Ukrainiens vont quand même se regrouper
autour de la table et se réjouir
car nous savons que des millions
d'Ukrainiens veulent la même chose font
faire les mêmes vœux tous nous voulons
la victoire notre victoire
oui
nous savons que
l'Ukraine est forte grâce à votre aide
nous avons développé des garanties de
sécurité pour notre pays pour l'Europe
et pour le monde avec vous et avec vous
nous allons
à leur place
pour y mettre à leur place tous ceux qui
s'opposent à la liberté
ce sera la base de la protection de la
démocratie en Europe et dans le monde
mais maintenant en ce temps de Noël je
tiens à vous remercier vous toutes vous
tous
je remercie toutes les familles
américaines
qui savent goûter la chaleur de leur
foyer et qui souhaite à d'autres de
vivre la même chose
je remercie le président Bayern et les
deux chambres pour votre appui constant
je remercie vos villes et vos citoyens
qui ont appuyé l'Ukraine qui avait
accueilli nos concitoyens
qui grandissent notre drapeau et qui
nous aide et qui nous soutiennent merci
de la part de tous ceux et celles qui
sont en première ligne de la part de
tous ceux et celles qui
attendent la victoire ici aujourd'hui je
rappelle les guerres de ce que disait le
président Francine de la norosvelt qui
conviennent particulièrement aujourd'hui
le peuple américain
va
l'emporter
remporter deux victoires décisives le
peuple ukrainien aussi va remporter lui
aussi cette victoire essentielle
ah non
je sais que tout dépend de nous les
forces armées ukrainiennes mais aussi
beaucoup dépend du monde et beaucoup de
choses dans le monde dépendent de vous
quand j'étais à barcoût hier
nos héros m'ont remis le drapeau
l'étendard de du combat les tendeurs de
ceux qui défendent l'Ukraine l'Europe et
le monde ont pris de leur vie ils m'ont
demandé de vous apporter ce drapeau ici
au Congrès des États-Unis de le
présenter aux membres de la Chambre des
Représentants et du Sénat dont les
décisions peuvent sauver des millions de
personnes
alors prenez ces décisions et que ce
drapeau reste ici
mesdames messieurs ce drapeau est le
symbole de notre victoire dans cette
guerre
nous nous tenons nous battons et nous
emporté parce que nous sommes unis nous
les Ukrainiens les États-Unis et tout le
monde libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le drapeau qui a flotté au-dessus
du Capitole aujourd'hui en l'honneur de
la visite du président de
[Applaudissements]